I could keep my eyes walking on you all
day
oh my gosh what are we about to do go to
Mexican which actor that British today
we're going to Mexico
yeah Mexico going to Mexico Mexico
bringing wall ahead
what other haha it's neither
he always sounds like a fruit
I'm leaving a fruit yeah so excited for
you to read my dad see I feel like you
guys will get along you guys are both
like movie buffs and you guys are both
goofy and I think you guys will get
along are you nervous no yes no I don't
know I can't I can't tell you the most
thing I'm excited about though is you
meeting my dad but your parents though
his parents are actually gonna meet us
out ahead of the last five days over
there so that's what I'm most excited
about to see like parents meeting my dad
and like my desk I believe I'm like that
I've never witnessed this is something
that wasn't planned but um I proposed
her just a few weeks ago but we had
clannish trip almost a year ago and so
it's almost kind of like a family Union
of joining like both our families
together and so it's so fitting the fact
that we just got engaged so know we've
kind of worked out that way perfect yeah
the timing was perfect because of the
engagement I feel like there's an added
pressure that's what I'm nervous about
I don't know it's like now now they're
not gonna see me at all he's the
boyfriend now he's like you better take
care of her or else we're gonna have
some problems you know like okay I might
be on my best behavior somebody that's
what I'll be telling you but I'm super
excited in your dad
are a lot of legendary stories about
your dad yeah my dad is group while he's
literally like a child knocking a man's
body
I hadn't seen America now the last time
I was in Mexico was for Christmas 2012
that's the last time I went hey Isaac do
you remember anything from Mexico last
time you were there no everyone
remembers playing again I kept educated
this and one side right here and I
didn't sting like a went through like
video
that's the only thing year ever really
happen what time I never told you this
but there's a cactus oh I forgot
Sunday's close buddy I Jerry
okay here we can get on it everything
I've ended there for a 10-minute 1000
years you know I'd say I got you I'm
gonna help you with magical hands
we'll take it
it's really high here looking for
sweating a lot how's it feel to be in
Mexico
normally the kissing I excited you were
he's a big baby I'm like telling this
kid every five minutes we'd be testing
in YouTube and then there's people
commenting like man the boy needs
chapstick like I know guys I told him
all the time I'm headed to my grandma's
house excited for you to see my
grandma's house it's like my towels over
there
let's do it the first we're gonna go to
my grandma's
I'm ready to go with the flow
yeah so my own powers just telling me
as crazy and
telling my family like scared a little
clearly a foreigner so that you can
you can blend in your eyes like I'm kind
of scared because I've never liked
unlike
just be careful you just don't stand out
you don't blend in
my uncle's like not jealous
I think this trip is going to be like
the most
nice
Thank You gracias nah
it's weird that I'm here it's weird that
I love you all right we're here Jeff
just said it's weird that I'm here Oh
uncle Nestle when I picked up my grandma
yeah your dad
looks just like you yeah Oh my kid is
yeah and that's Isaac - everyone wants
to save your family I told Owen like
Isaac did not want to learn Spanish
growing up and I kept forcing him yes
got in trouble and I like schools in
because he didn't want to learn they
were like oh really come over here but
it's funny I don't wanna don't point at
me
yeah keep one watch until like it'll be
rude all right so when I used to live in
this house I this is my room Oh over
here is this the way that I'm here it is
like I'm kind of process every week so
many memory so my uncle Haman my
Mikell or a they had like their own
pizza business so they were like do
stuff
oh right you know this is pizza business
right it was here and I'm here oh these
stairs staircase is crazy and my aunt
house
you can get lost here I didn't you would
never expect this to be up here yeah
it's a whole nother house oh this is my
ass that's pretty much the same the only
difference is when I would live here
this week
okay this temporary I'm sure I can see
now I said in Hong Kong reminds you of
Mexico cuz the shake of Hong Kong now I
told you it reminds me like when I went
to Hong Kong I'm like do it or any a lot
of Mexico alright we are going back down
this looks really crazy I don't know
this is a really good idea to shoot this
and to go down same time it looks cool
this is your future wife my teacher oil
how do you that very happy
yeah me too I'm very happy to have in my
own family
yeah she loves you so much thank you I
love you too thank you so much to you
thank you Oh
mucho hot oh so hot oh oh you're trying
how cute is that Kevin big I just gonna
spend the night at my grandma's house
with my hand in my cousin even try your
best
just get into the hotel room and you got
an awesome ask you with review of the
famous Cathedral of 100 as he drove I
don't know Cathedral know that we're all
settled into the hotel we're gonna go
visit in my life written so far Hopkins
and explore a little bit of Mexico
hey hey what's this
I'm too scared I don't want it like get
lost or get stolen or something
so I'm not wearing my ring when we're in
public
I take it off and I have my secret that
only you guys will know which is a lot
of people thinking the secret Noble
pretty much I created my own like ring
holder thing and so there's like this
keychain here and I have some good see I
think traveling creates a sense of
stress that you don't normally account
for it doesn't seem like we did that
much today but defined it we're
traveling you right I don't know for me
I'm meeting like tist family there's
like a sense of like stress there that
takes a toll I think so I feel I felt be
what about you lay down next to me
man I got us do a set up real quick your
hairy stomach I know the rain messed it
up
I feel like today all day today I've
been kind of like processing everything
that's happening I'll be it really hit
me that we're here yet oh it hit me I
don't know I don't understand anything
that's happening around me now I feel
like it's gonna really hit me once I see
my dad like he's like my dad and my
sister make those two before like people
that I'm like dying to see already but
my dad said that he's on his way from
Mexico City now so but I gotta pick my
father-in-law
yeah how cute okay I'm trying not to get
my hopes up though because my dad does
have a tendency to like break his
promises so I'm just trying to like
better be here tomorrow or else um he's
gonna get an earful from me we should go
to some really tired to be continued
we're gonna meet her dad next episode
hopefully he come hey good night